so we hope you join us tomorrow for our
founders day we're going to mark the
25th anniversary of our company nexstar
and you are invited to help us help
nonprofits in the valley
you can drop off and donate canned and
non-perishable food bottled water and
clothes
right here to channel 8 just come to
3228 channel 8 drive or right near the
convention center
tomorrow from 6 a.m until 6 pm just
drive up we'll take your donations
this year we're giving back to the
salvation army and three square
food bank and on that note joining us
live to talk about uh
three square food bank and the uh how
your donations will help them
it's larry scott chief operating officer
at three square larry it's good to see
you once again this morning how you
doing
good morning thank you for having me so
let's talk about where things stand
right now with regards to food
insecurity and the efforts by three
square and how folks tomorrow can really
help out
well food insecurities at a very
very high level which probably comes as
little surprise to our community
we as much as 15 percent of our
community is food insecure
at any given time during the month so
uh it's a very very large number of
people that need help in our community
what can people bring we always talk
about the non-perishable food items are
there are certain things in particular
that folks
should bring tomorrow yeah canned goods
or any type of
shelf staple type of items are good that
have a long shelf life
and that are uh don't present as much
food safety challenges for us so
that's the type of products that we look
for in and donate from
from households we're watching some
video from past founders days here at
eight news now as
the community has helped out when
possible which we always enjoy
larry i remember you and i had a
discussion at the beginning of the
pandemic
about the challenges three square was
facing then we saw the food banks that
had been set up at uh
at the boulder i think it was boulder
station i think palace station a bunch
of the casinos all over the valley
and the challenges that the casinos
weren't open and a lot of the food that
three square gets
would be from the casinos where do
things stand now
in terms of not only our recovery but
just three square trying to get ahead of
the situation
well we had to um adjust almost daily
uh as uh the pandemic first hit and uh
fortunately we were really we were
blessed to be able to get a
a substantial amount of federal
commodities brought in and that was
critical
they were able to jump the supply chain
problem that existed in the market and
so
so we were able to get plenty of food in
here to the community
and now we're just kind of adjusting
back to days of old
and getting back to face-to-face
delivery of food and we're looking
forward to that
and when you say larry days of old
certainly that's i guess a good thing in
some regards in terms of things getting
back to normal but for
you know what you do and the people that
you're serving normal
is still a very big challenge normal is
absolutely still a challenge and part of
that is because
our agency partners who are so critical
in this effort
who we deliver the food to that we
source
they they were hurt in a great way uh
many of them have not opened back up and
so
we've had to rebuild our distribution
system somewhat as we
as we come back out of the pandemic but
uh we've had a lot of help
and a lot of really good contributors to
making that happen
well hopefully we can do a some part to
help with that as well in the community
and our viewers can as well tomorrow
once again larry thank you very much
we're showing some of the details for
three square food bank on our screen
we'll see you here at the station
tomorrow we look forward to that as well